wollen du und marie bald zusammenziehen
keine frage
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut
heute steht was wirklich cooles an und
zwar ist das ganze in kooperation mit
snap chat ja da muss ich erst mal direkt
sagen freundlich mega dass das geklappt
hat weil ich bin wirklich eigentlich
snapshot user der ersten stunde ich weiß
noch als das damals rausgekommen ist das
war bei uns in der city irgendwie direkt
so ein ziemlich großer hype und wir
haben uns darüber halt immer fotos
verschickt alles mögliche ich glaube da
war ich so einer neunten oder zehnten
klasse also da hängen wirklich viele
erinnerungen oder viele erinnerungen
kommen damit und ich würde dem ganzen
auch treu geblieben also ich koste immer
noch ziemlich viele snaps dort könnt ihr
mir gerne folgen ich könnte euch jemand
meinen usernamen ein falls hier und ich
hab ich als entrance hat natürlich auch
den wandel der fw mitbekommen es kommen
viele neue features sind zu wirklich
eine menge hat sich verändert und das
wollen wir uns halt mal anschauen
wir wollen uns aber später auch ein paar
fragen von euch anschauen gleichkommt
marie noch dazu die macht denn auch mit
marie freut sich schon gleich ihre
lieblings lenz die dann an mir
ausprobiert wird euch zu zeigen weil das
ist wirklich also wie das aussieht
komplett verrückt ich zeige euch mal
ganz kurz mein profil so heißt hier alex
re ich habe schon 49.500 53 punkte das
ist schon viel
ja das ist schon eine menge ich weiß ja
auch freundin haben so 300.000 wir
schauen uns jetzt erstmal die neue
lanxess an
du wolltest mir zeigt mir einmal deine
lieblings lions allem ja sagt den leuten
das mach ich hoffe ich habe die hierauf
dabei die machst du an deinem handy
bei mir sieht das halt voll anders aus
als auf deinem handy oder hallo herr
anders dass sie noch verrückter als
maria jetzt noch mal bei dir
also ich finde ich sie hier schon aus
wie so ein ganz anderer kleiner junge
liegen ganz andere kennen ja also anders
als bei dir noch eine vielleicht welchen
benutzte meister
[Musik]
das ist deine lieblingsband aber nicht
mit diesem mit der softbox sieht es
nicht so gut aus softbox und natürlich
nicht besser aus also da muss ich sagen
das gefällt mir auch vom alter gangster
gangster das ist man den habe ich früher
mal verwendet oder ihr geht jetzt auch
zu zweit also das als herauskam dass hat
das war ganz krass und dafür stellt sich
auch die stimme da sehe ich voll
erwachsen und aus mit dem oder dann
machen wir mal einen pick eben mit
blitzen und ohne und jetzt ohne blondel
ceo das ist jetzt wichtig wenn es wenn
es nämlich kalt wird da ist ne da
brauchst du nicht mal eine winterjacke
da kann es einfach die ihr nehmen gar
kein problem
oder oh ja das wäre doch was für dich
dir ist doch immer so kalt
das sind dann so minispielen wie kannst
du zum beispiel eine stadt bauen halt so
mit freunden auch unter anderem daneben
hier kann man das ist auch leiste das
habe ich auch nicht anders auch jetzt
zeigt hier
kommen weiter weiter weiter weiter ich
hatte schon mal über 200 mann du musst
du willst nicht so gut schaffen wie habe
ich ja gesagt du hast ja vorher noch nie
gespielt hast du hast du ein foto
gemacht
leute wir spielen jetzt gleich eventuell
mal sogar gegeneinander technology
partie das ist ein absolut geniales game
da kannst du so minispiele mit einer
laut auch gegen fremde zorn und marie
danke dass du mitgemacht hast später
werden noch fragen gestellt von
zuschauern auf andere leute wird zocken
jetzt eine runde mit mühe die partie
da gibt es eine menge minispiele es
kommt immer wieder was neues also checkt
das mag ich gehe hier einfach auf den
chat mit irgendeinem freund von mir hat
besonders traurige post mit demenz und
dann geht man hier auf die rakete und
kann hier zum beispiel mit mode party
auswählen so das wird dann gestartet wir
zocken jetzt einfach mal drauflos und
der sucht halt sowieso irgendwelche
spieler irgendwo auf der welt das hier
ist mein mit mojo hier unten der mit dem
blonden haaren früher hatte ich noch
blonde haare ich habe schon einen hohen
geholt wie man gerade sehen konnte so
und jetzt geht's auch schon los jetzt
wird der game master bestimmt der kommt
aus united kingdom und der muss uns
jetzt weg catchen praktika ich bin jetzt
schon runter alter das war schlecht ja
das habe ich bestanden
ok also man muss immer über dieses ding
hüpfen das war wieder eng
ich bin gut dabei ich bin gut dabei ich
muss ja ok weiter weiter weiter
nein man okay ein habe ich glaube ich
noch ein lied oh ich hab ich hab
gewonnen oder ja leute der winner hier
die beiden männer ok 20 points für mich
ein minispiel feierlich am meisten ich
hoffe das kommt jetzt gleichauf scheiße
darum bin ich schlecht
ich muss jetzt aufpassen dass ich hier
nicht irgendwie in den pool rein 14
gehen wir mal schnell nach hinten da
darf mich jetzt abwerfen der game master
okay ich gewinnen dass leute ist gar
kein problem einfach nur die ruhe
bewahren kommen jetzt gibt es sogar noch
ein paar points für mich
die eine ist vector okay dachte fliegt
bis zu mir kommen der kann mir gar
nichts anhaben nur noch zwei sekunden
und win win win win war wohl schon
wieder reingeholt weit das ist mir neu
dass kenne ich noch gar nicht okay worum
geht's hier
es werde ich bestimmt game master
herr schon wieder united kingdom werde
dein ziel wird jede runde mit essen
jetzt trägt er hier der krieg das mit
mir zu tun
junge was ich bin raum ist das war es
und das ist der winner läuft gerade
einfach letzter das spiel kenn ich auch
noch nicht also es gibt so viele
verschiedene minispiele hier aber man
muss sich einfach hier vor dem nicht
verstecken einfach wegrennen
ich verstecke mich hier in der ecke
einfach fakten nein nein er hat mich er
hat mich wann man eigentlich kann man so
schlecht sein am anfang lief es gut
naja leute egal ich würde sagen wir
beantworten jetzt ein paar fragen ich
habe einige snaps bekommen von euch per
video also ich bin wirklich manchmal
aktiv und antworten wir aufpassen apps
ist immer cool drückt mir unbedingt bei
snap paris endlich wieder da wo wir
beantworten jetzt noch ein paar fragen
die mir gestellt wurden auch snap chat
auch an dich marie deswegen ist es super
dass du vom einkaufen wieder da wirst du
darfst gerne mit beantworten gefragt wie
lange brauchst du ungefähr um ein video
zu schneiden
ja ich ungefähr eine halbe stunde was
was soll das denn heißen also an manchen
videos zusätzlich auch zwei bis drei
stunden die sind meistens nicht so
aufwendig das stimmt leute das stimmt
nicht ich schneide schon mindestens
immer eine halbe stunde an reaction
videos und an videos für meine
hauptkanal ein bis zwei bis drei stunden
zeit wollte fragen bist du auch bei
deinen eltern in der stadt alle zwei
wochen zu zeitweilig auch viel zeit
haben gleich geht es wieder hin marie
kommt auch mit habe ich bin krank leute
ich will dich kannst du seinen eltern
gut habt ihr vor nach corona zu reisen
und wenn ja wohin
ja auf jeden fall erstmal warten wie
lange es noch dauert und dann will ich
sagen
santorini
da wollen wir unbedingt noch einmal
wollen und marie bald zusammenziehen
meine frage ja ja wann dann
marco ist im august schon so früh schon
bist du dir sicher wenn er mir willst du
zusammen bist also das würde ich mir
auch zweimal überlegen
also vielleicht machen wir das wirkt
schon erreicht dann immer wieder für
videos ausgenutzt das ist im darüber
haupt nicht die leute spaß beiseite also
wir haben wirklich vor im august oder so
das ja wahrscheinlich so im august dann
zusammen zu ziehen
ob das klappt wäre da ja sehen wie lange
das gut geht ja so wenn irgendwer 23
monate später ein schwarzes bild in
unserer story ist wenn wir uns ein paar
tage später dazu melden wissen bescheid
hat nicht funktioniert ja leute so viel
dazu ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen holt
euch auf jeden fall snap chat im app
store oder google place tor wo auch
immer ich kann es euch nur empfehlen ist
eine geile app danke dass das geklappt
hat und ja das nach oben da abonniert
den kanal wir sehen uns nächste woche
montag wieder hier jetzt immer montag
mittwoch und freitag gibt es im video
das was mir haut rein
ciao
[Musik]